ci siamo ragazzi siamo ritornati su un
episodio di api messe in dieci minuti
perché voglio male a me stesso abbiamo
fa quasi tutti i top livelli in dieci
minuti ovvero dieci minuti io non senza
tagli devo provare a fare più livelli
possibili abbiamo fatto l'impossibile
abbiamo fatto di rock swing mancano gli
spike fall
il vostro è un paio di altre cosine io
direi che oggi possiamo fare gli spikes
fall perché sono tra i livelli tifosi di
happy with molto difficili al mio tre
parte countdown 123 via allora primo
spyphone di oggi che non significa fare
una cosa di decente spero riusciva ad
almeno almeno dieci tratto questa vita
che lo spy phone più votato al mondo
ragazzi perché quando faccio sort by
rating stilata mies con i livelli più
quotati al mondo quindi teoricamente
questo lo spy phone il preferito del del
secolo
non ho idea il motivo però l'ho fatto va
bene il primo ok già uno non so se
riesco a tenere conto però facciamo qui
alla fine ci riusciva a tenere conto
perché riusciva a fare solo quello che è
successo qua ma che poi c'è un muro non
vale cosa succede
cos'è sta roba agli 8 c'è un muro non
vale questo dato a saltare così è
successo lì hanno forse perché volevano
spector finto non c'è un muro non
capisce un muro bene solo saltiamo a
fango ore mai fatto parte 20 secondi
l'ex coach era un muro non andava bene
allora uno per a nessuno solo porca
vacca di mitezza ho beccato beccare uno
sbagliato le scott
io non so ragazzi quanti voi poi ci poi
dopo il video ci provano ma fate
veramente difficile porca vacca cielo
arrivato let's go dai staccati vasta
roba staccare di testa fa niente
rifacciamolo oltre 40 circola l'edizione
ne ho fatto solo uno e spero di fare
almeno una mia almeno una al minuto c'è
la cosa che dovrei riuscire a fare per
adesso in tutti quelli che ho fatti
dieci minuti sono sempre vinti
abbastanza bene ovviamente questo sarà
quello dove farlo schifo porca vacca
manettino sempre ste cose
maledizione ma quanto è difficile questo
ragazzi di spy phone sono così purtroppo
alle volte azzecchi e le volte no in
avanti port cavalcato riuscire a fare un
salto a metà cosa che veramente
difficile
ok forse questo è un fatto ragazzi e
forse questo ho fatto perfetto 2883
perfetto anche max pezzali guest
speciale del video 2
siamo a 8 minuti quindi più o meno uno
al minuto ragazzi a mele si è fatto
perdere 20 secondi quel secondo livello
stupido porca vacca edizione chissà se
qualcuno ci ha infilato il mio nome in
mezzo vengo sempre fini by chuck norris
e ste robe ce l'abbiamo fatta ci abbiamo
fatto questo è giusto questo è buono
questo è bello 3 perfetto questo qua ok
ragazzi dove scegliere il personaggio va
come perché ci sono degli aran as
maledizione soprattutto malissimo
si vabbè ma credo sia meglio farlo con
con enti perché successo se non c'è
scherzavo vere così 4 1 2 3 4 sì
prefetto vai
non so contare infatti quattro ragazzi
lecco sta aumentando la velocità perché
ho preso un pochettino lavano perfetto
ok stavolta ce la faccio stata ce la
faccio e buone vuole buono mia sorella è
buona porca barca perché c'è nulla ciak
che si lamentano iwata è parte livello
dai vacanze minuti col demonio parco ce
la fai a centrare maledizione spingiti
porca vacca
bollati malati bravo questo è giusto
questo è giusto forse no maledizione
ragazzi solissimo è diventato dark souls
sto gioco all'improvviso maledizione
alla vita ragazzi di odio gli spyphone
lo devo farlo lo sarebbe possiamo
cambiare in corso d'opera facciamo un pò
troppi di così non so che fare ok no no
no no no non ho toccato troppo in fretta
porca vacca ragazza impossibile il
quinto non riesco a farlo impossibile
staccati piedi la goldman aragami
annuncia posso fare mi store c'è il
server sto perdendo gli ultimi neuroni
che ho io ancora che deciso di fare
happy visse nella mia vita
porca vacca basta nonno hai rotto
cioè su giuseppe maria 5 l'abbiamo fatti
allora 5 mancano 5 minuti dai forse
riesco ad arrivare a 10 1 al minuto
maledizione questo magari mi devo
buttare un po di te perché le pendenze
sono né che sono sempre uguali sono
diverse ogni livello è quello il casino
che ogni volta devi prendere una roba
diversa
devi più o meno tar arti con le scritte
che sono veramente impossibile
facciamo pure lei se ci manca solo
quello facciamoli kiss costanti 6
quest'ora anche difficile e vabbè ma se
li metti il coso in testa cosa come
faccio porca vacca non posso svetta
facciamo cambiamo cambiamo personaggio
mediò mettimi nonno ciak meraviglioso 7
non so neanche come updater vai via via
via buonissimo buonissimo lo ho fatto
una roba incredibile pro facciamoci in
charter perché è troppo lungo questo
ragazzi quattro minuti infatti 7 veloce
questo la vedo dura ai ragazzi questo la
vedo veramente dura madonna questo è
lunghissimo
c'è questo qua perfino ci vogliono sei
anni sempre troppo anche questo ormai lo
so già prima ancora del salto parte che
non vedo è tutto nero non vedo la
piattaforma li mortacci mia quanto
difficile ragazzi siamo ritornati in
pari col tempo maledizione questo è
buono c'è ma ti pare che alla fine muoio
no ragazzi manca veramente due minuti e
57 sono scivolato però buono buonissimo
dovevo scivolare per vincere perché non
ha fregato 88 due minuti e 47 veloce
questo tra l'altro con il padre di uk e
non ho mai vista sta roba vaio che vinci
tu ma come cosa vedo le palle va bene un
rito nobel ne mancano per farne uno su
due minuti e mezzo e mi abbiano battuto
il senso arrivata al mio risultato
quello che volevo fare io
10 va bene vediamo conto riesco a fare
veloce almeno 15 adesso spike col prof
ok va bene proviamoci e vabbè ma questo
è il dritto e stranissimo di andare
proprio incipiente non devi colpire e
come fai a centrare il coso va bene non
me ne frega niente questo nello spazio
vai però cavalca possiamo dallo spazio
bellissimo 299 il 29 non è il ragazzo
che mi faceva i livelli una volta
attenzione porca vacca dai la temi 13 13
13 13 maledizione perché non sapete cosa
che cela c'è la luna il club quello che
non è la luna quella di meteorite ma fa
niente
cioè sta roba qua che tonda e quindi non
riesco a darmi lo slancio dritto perché
tonda scivolo sembra di giocare che i
poveri maledizione un minuto il 24 per
farne due
14 meraviglioso e non so se l'attrice 14
mi sono dimenticato non mi ricordo
quanto sto facciamo 14 poi tanto riconto
che manca dai un minuto per farne uno
arriviamo a 15 che è molto meglio di
pensa di farne 10 15 ne scopre jaco 16
57 secondi o mio dio
eva ha fregato le scritte erano multiple
non saltare mai dritto prova dritto
bravissimo parlo con i miei personaggi
ragazzi lo faccio spesso vedete funziona
16 17 così random benissimo 17 18 se mi
butto è vinco vale sono no ma mi sa che
non vincerò e niente ragazzi siamo a
zero
ne ho fatti 18 allora li contiamo in
attivo per essere sicuri 9 10 11 12 dei
14 come 15 ma porca vacca ho sbagliato
non riesco a contare 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 questo non l'ho fatto e
15 ma alla fine ho con me ne sono
aggiunti tre per sbaglio in realtà ne ho
fatti 15 mo mi sembra avere fatti 18
non so contare faccio youtuber per un
motivo ragazzi però va bene non so
contare ma 15 st ippolito riccamente li
ho fatti in dieci minuti quindi più di
uno al minuto non male è normale perché
poteva andarmi molto peggio molto peggio
però va bene così
ragazzi miei spero mi sia piaciuto
lasciato un bel mi piace iscritti al
canale schiacciata campanili up rimanere
aggiornati sui nuovi video che escono e
la prossima volta farò il 10 ma in
realtà non l'ha proseguita vista che ci
sono le chat e quello che facciano i
cinque episodi quindi facili vedi top
però la prossima volta ancora però
quanti boltro riesco a fare in dieci
minuti quella ancora meglio però che
adesso secondo me questo non è un brutto
risultato anzi direi che ottimo poi
vabbè è arrivata 20 che che vedevo di
però per adesso direi che ci siamo bravi
sia piaciuto iscrivetevi e per ragazzi
[Musica]
ma